sorti aujourd'hui en france du dernier
livre d'helmut newton portrait paru chez
nathan est un événement dans le monde de
la photo newton devenue la des
photographes de mode le plus célèbre
dans les 60 reste aujourd'hui le plus
connu en prise de vue à paris pour deux
jours car linkedin cela observé portrait
autoportrait hughton narcisse new town
voyeur son univers la mode le sexe le
pouvoir pas seulement au regard une
fascination son livre peut-être à newton
plus intime de même ma cousine du temps
la poétesse car c'est une femme
formidable
chez les hommes qu'est ce qui vous
attire autre gros changement des hommes
justes les hommes se seraient pas
vraiment montreux hommage aux femmes aux
femmes célèbres à la beauté mais aussi
hommage à sa femme joue à qui il
dédicace son livre